to george clooney and his ocean's pal
matt damon at the venice film festival
carly steele is with george for his
first interview since becoming a new dad
yes nancy we're here at palestine on the
grand canal the celebrity hot spot
during the festival and we just spoke
with george and matt who are now both
part of the hollywood dance club
did you ever imagine you would be coming
back
with three babies ella alexander and
suburbicon
i see what you did you know i like what
you did
you know i fee and even in this
windstorm you still have it i'll be
honest
um no i i really honestly i didn't think
i'd be
married with two kids
fatherhood has done little to dampen
george's charming wit humor as he
explains to us their distinct
personalities starting with alexander
he's a thug already
you saw him he's a moose
literally he just sits in the east like
this
he looks like he could bounce right now
it's like checking ids on the way into
the
nursery i mean she's very elegant in all
eyes she looks like a mall as for the
origin of the names uh
we just didn't want to have really dumb
names how do you feel fatherhood has
changed you
it's made me much older
well back in march when we spoke to you
matt you said in terms of fatherhood i
think george will be a mess but amal
will just do it all have you changed
your opinion not at all
really it's true he's got me i'm a mess
but she's happy she's like an olympic
athlete she's got it you know you got
two kids you're breastfeeding like crazy
i'm very good by the way at diaper
changing are you oh yes what's your
strategy well i get them right around my
hips and oh
oh i don't know i suppose just the
minute they came out and you're like
they're covered in
you know slime and crying and you're
like oh wait a minute what is that we
were just two and now we're poor
george and matt are at the venice film
festival to premiere their new thriller
suburbicon the film marks the fourth
time george has directed his good friend
now that i've got kids matt gives me
direction oh really
what kind of questions
i have no idea how he's doing it it's
crazy
george hasn't attended the venice film
festival since 2013 when he promoted
gravity alongside sandra bullock and he
applauds her generous 1 million dollar
donation to help hurricane harvey
victims
like amal and i talked about it we're
going to be
donating a considerable amount of money
as well this could take a long time
you